le comité les amis les admire depuis
longtemps
philippe vous avez écrit 30 livres dont
vous dites que ce sont plutôt des
articles de 300 pages voyais souvent
et puis là d'un seul coup vous nous
montrez des maximes personnelles que
vous gardiez pour vous secrètement et
vous publié sous le titre de penser au
cherche midi
alors si vous aviez une minute pour me
le vendre selon vous diriez quoi je
dirais que j'ai mis quarante ans à
l'écrire et que vous mettrez 40 minutes
tel lire ouais c'est pas mal comme je
vous sais très occupé vous dites que
vous n'êtes plus moraliste que moral ça
veut dire quoi
j'te jure que la morale je m'en fous
mais qu' il faut quand même expliquer
aux gens que la vie n'est qu'une norme
bouffonnerie qu'on vit dans une société
d'obsédé d'hypocrite et qu'il faut se
méfier quoi surtout mais là je fais un
travail de salubrité publique
mais je le fais comme tout le monde
pourrait le faire à mon argent qu au nom
de l'ancienneté de l'expérience puis
d'une petite réflexion
imaginez